what I hope to do in this video is give
ourselves some practice interpreting
statements and writing them as
mathematical expressions possibly using
parentheses so let's get started and for
any of these statements if you get so
inspired and encourage you to get so
inspired pause the video and see if you
can write them as mathematical
expressions so this first one says seven
hundred minus 19 divided in half so we
could say we another way to think about
divided in half is divided by two so we
could write this as seven hundred and
nine minus 19 and we're going to do that
first so that's why I put the
parentheses around it divided by 2 or
divided in half that's one way that we
could write this now the next one and
once again pause it if you get inspired
and I encourage you to three times the
sum of 56 and seven so it's going to be
3 times the sum of 56 and seven so the
sum of 56 and seven we want to take that
first so it's going to be 56 plus seven
that's the sum of 56 and seven and then
we want to do three times that we want
to do three times this sum so we could
write it we could write it like that
another way we could write it when
you're dealing with parenthesis and
you're going to see this more and more
as you get into more and more fancy
algebra I guess you could say but what
I'm about to show you is it so fancy is
you don't have to write the
multiplication sign here you could just
write three and then open parenthesis 56
plus seven 56 56 plus seven and this too
is 3 times the sum of 56 and seven and
you want to be very careful because you
might be tempted to maybe do it without
the parentheses so you might be tempted
to do something like this 3 times 3
times 56 56 plus seven but this one
isn't obviously 3 times the sum of 56
and seven in fact the standard way to
interpret this is that you would do the
multiplication first you would do three
times 56 and then add 7 which is going
to give you a different
all you and you could try it out then if
you were to add the 56 and the seven
first so to make sure that you do the 56
and the seven first you want to put this
parenthesis around it so let's keep
going the sum of three times 56 and
seven so we're going to take the sum of
two things so we're going to take the
sum of two things the first thing that
we're going to take the sum of is three
times 56 so three times 56 and a seven
and then let me do that in a different
color and seven and seven so this right
over here is the sum of three times 56
and seven now it's always good to write
the parenthesis it makes it a little bit
cleaner a little bit more obvious that
look I'm going to take the three times
56 I'm going to do that first and then
I'm going to add seven but based on what
I just told you the standard way if you
were someone were to just write three
times 56 plus 7 plus already three times
56 if someone order just write this
three times 56 plus seven this actually
can still be interpreted as the sum of
three times 56 and seven because as I
just said the standard the convention so
to speak is to do your multiplication
first order of operations which you may
or may not but if you're not familiar
you will be familiar with it soon is to
do the multiplication first and then add
the seven and then do the addition but
just to make it clear it doesn't hurt to
put the parenthesis there three times 56
plus seven now we have 43 minus the sum
of 16 and 11 so 43 minus so we're going
to have 43 minus minus the sum of 16 and
11 so minus the sum of 16 and 11 so from
43 we're going to take the sum of 16 and
11 and so once again the parenthesis
make it clear that we're going to take
the sum of 16 and 11 and we're going to
take that from 43 parenthesis are very
very
very important here because if we just
did 4343 minus 16 minus 16 plus 11 the
standard way of interpreting this would
be 43 minus 16 and then adding 11 which
would give you a different value than 43
minus the sum of 16 and 11 so once again
the parentheses are very very very
important here to emphasize that you're
going to add the 16 and 11 first and
then subtract that sum from 43 this is
fun let's keep going ten times the
quotient of 104 and eight so we're going
to do 10 times something 10 times the
quotient of 104 and eight and so the
quotient of 104 and 8 we can write like
this 104 divided by divided by 8 or
based on what we told you a little
earlier you could write this as 10 times
the quotient the quotient of 104 and 8
or 104 divided by divided by 8 now let's
just do this last one four times as
large
so four four times as large as the
expression as the expression 175 minus
58 so I'm going to do four times as
large as something so I'm going to
multiply something times four and I'm
going to multiply as large as the
expression 175 minus 58 175 minus 58 and
once again I could write it as four
times four times as large as the
expression let me do that in that purple
color as the expression 175 minus 175
minus 58 either way and once again if
you were to do it like this if you
weren't right if you were it didn't
write the parentheses then it wouldn't
be the same thing because if the
parentheses weren't here then you would
want to do the 4 times 175 first and
then subtract the 58 which isn't what
this statement is telling us and this
last one I think brings up an
interesting thing for us to think about
because if someone were to walk up walk
up to you on the street and they were to
show you ups what's going on with my
computer and they were to show you two
different expressions is well the first
expression said said - let's write it
this way actually I'm not going to speak
them out I'm just going to going to
write it down I'm just going to write
some some crazy number here some crazy
some crazy numbers here so that's one
expression that someone were to write
and let's say another one is this one
and I'm intentionally but I put the
commas in the wrong place on let me make
sure I get this right all right this one
hundred eighty three thousand five
hundred seventy six this is thirty seven
thousand three hundred ninety nine so
that's one expression and then another
expression is this and I'm intentionally
not reading it out well I'll read it out
a little bit thirty-seven thousand three
hundred and ninety nine if someone said
quick which expression is larger and you
might be tempted or you might not be
tempted but you might be tempted oh let
me calculate this thing gee I'm gonna
have to write this thing down or use a
calculator or something or whatever else
to add one hundred eighty three five one
hundred eighty three thousand five
hundred 676 was thirty-seven thousand
three hundred ninety nine and then have
to multiply that by two and figure out
what that number is equal to and then I
would have to take one hundred eighty
three thousand five hundred seventy-six
plus thirty seven thousand three hundred
ninety nine figure out what that is
multiply that by seven and figure out
what that's going to be that's that's
hard that's going to take not hard it's
just going to take you some time you
might make some careless mistakes but
the big realization to say well which
one is larger well I don't have to even
calculate these things because this is
two times this this craziness right over
here this thing that's going to be two
hundred something thousand and this is
seven times that thing that is going to
be two hundred and something thousand so
seven times that thing is going to be
larger than two times that thing and so
one way to you know before you dive deep
and start computing things it's always
good to take a step back and say hey
look can I look at kind of how the
expressions are formed the structure of
these
Russians and say look this is this is
two times this thing and this is seven
times this thing well the seven is going
to be this one right over here is going
to be is going to be a larger expression
anyway hopefully you enjoyed that as
much as I did